I think there should be a parade I
endorse the parade there should be a
parade can you imagine a men's Day
parade with masculine men and you know
all that toxic masculinity on display
imagine a parade of all fit men
firefighters and construction workers
and successful guys who run businesses
can you imagine the feminist outrage at
that first of all you would never be
able to do it because you would have to
have now a woke men's parade it would be
like men appreciation day and they would
be like women who became men there would
be like I would it would it would it
would be crazy right but interesting
that there is a men's day and none of us
know about it because nobody cares oh
that's interesting none of the covers of
the magazines covered that how odd
foreign